on the banks of the saudi river people
gather to pray in the ancient town of
ayodhya
preparations are underway ahead of the
construction of a temple at the site
that hindus believe is the birthplace
of their guard rama
the ram temple is supported by all
indians only some who wanted to spread
hate were opposed to it
controversy over the site has led to
some of the worst religious violence in
india's history
and security has been heightened in 1992
thousands of hindus from around the
country came to the town
and destroyed the 16th century babari
mosque
and 22 others 18 of the muslims living
in the town were killed including
relatives of thaibon nisha and muhammad
shahid
we lost everything in the violence my
sawmill was here
we had thousands of dollars worth of
wood they set
everything on fire they killed my
husband and brother-in-law
they tore up the quran in our mosque and
started stamping on the pages
we tried collecting the pages the
atmosphere kept getting worse
they started attacking people here
[Music]
the religious violence spread beyond
ayodhya muhammad shahid's father and
uncle were two of more than 2 000 people
who were killed around the country
leading members of the hindu nationalist
bharatiya jantapati are on trial for
conspiring to destroy the mosque
the bjp had long promised to build a ram
temple
this is the fulfillment of the bjp's
promise to the nation
and this is a defining moment for india
the party gained more political support
after the mosque's destruction
once bgp started movement surrounding
babri masjid
then gradually it became a symbol of you
know india's secularism that is where
the destruction really created a new
kind of political environment
created new kind of political force and
that force ultimately is now ruling the
country
the bjp were first elected to govern the
country in the general election
following the mosque's destruction
after the legal battles over the site's
ownership the supreme court ruled last
year that it belongs to hindus
now 30 years after he joined the
campaign for iran temple
prime minister narendra modi is
inaugurating its construction
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi